-Nicholas, thank you
for being here on the show.
I appreciate it.
-Great to be here.
This is so exciting, man.
-No -- It is. I am --
-I've been a fan for so long.
So this is --
Yeah, this is awesome.
-We've actually --
We've met before once.
Do you remember that?
-Yeah, I do. I do. Um...
Kind of a weird dinner, right?
Kind of a weird crew.
-It was a little odd, right?
-Yeah, it was a little odd.
-What was that again?
-It was very intimate.
It was, like, Senator John Kerry
and some, like, bank CEOs,
Goldman Sachs backing CEO.
-Sounds like my crowd
I roll with.
-Yeah, me too. Yeah.
Big financial
kind of contingent.
-Yeah.
-We were all solo.
It was -- Nobody had a plus one.
So it was kind of like
a meet-and-greet.
-Seems like "Squid Game."
-[ Laughter ]
-What was it?
-I don't know.
-Yeah, it was odd.
-Yeah. We were at opposite ends
of the table.
And I was like, "I got to talk
to Jimmy, but I don't know how."
'Cause do I ask, like,
you know, Gayle King to stand up
so that I can move her
and sit next to you?
-Yeah.
Gayle King was there, as well.
-Yeah, Gayle --
Arianna Huffington.
We're just going to name drop --
We're just going to drop names.
-Was J.J. Watt there?
-J.J. Watt was there. Exactly.
-What's your small talk?
What's your go-to
when we're at these dinners?
-You know, banks. Banks are --
-That's not true.
-Banks are big, you know?
-I know, but we weren't talking
about banks, were we?
-No, no. I guess -
-I have no idea about banks.
-I don't know -- Yeah. I have
a Bank of America account.
-You can't point to the crowd
like they're going to clap.
You think that
they're going to clap?
"Hey, well,
I do have an ATM card.
What's up? You guys know
what I'm talking about?
No big deal."
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Citibank, boo!"
-Oh, my God.
-"Bank of America, yeah!"
-Oh, my -- That is ridiculous.
-Banks are sick.
-Anyways, I'm glad
you're finally on the show.
-Me too.
-You look sharp, buddy.
I want to talk about
"Succession."
You -- Cousin Greg, just --
I mean, honestly every scene
that you're in, you steal.
You don't have to react to that.
You already have one Emmy
nomination under your belt.
-That's really nice. Thank you.
-And I'm sure
you're gonna have much more.
Do people try to hit you up
for spoilers?
Not like I'm doing that tonight,
but...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People want spoilers.
-Yeah. Not me.
-You're good?
-If you feel like
telling me something...
I mean, is it about
banking or whatever?
Whatever you feel
like telling me, I'm down.
I mean, who is
the most famous person
that tried to hit you up
for spoilers?
-You know, I -- Bradley Cooper.
-What?
-Bradley Cooper...
-Yeah.
-...is a big "Succession" fan.
And I didn't know it.
I was invited to his house.
Jeremy Strong and him
have become buddies.
And, so, I was invited over
to watch some football.
Not a big football guy,
but I was like,
"This is awesome.
I love Bradley Cooper."
Huge, like, idol of mine.
And so I went over,
and he has so many theories.
He was like,
"What -- Like, when Shiv,
like, looked this way,
what did that mean?
Like, I think
it meant this or that."
-And he's a charmer,
Bradley Cooper.
-Absolutely.
-So I would just
tell him everything.
-Yeah. He's --
-I'd say,
"Here's the ending, dude.
Leave me alone, man."
-Totally.
-"Get that icy stare
away from me, yeah."
-He's so handsome.
-He's a handsome dude. Yeah.
-He gets really close when
he talks to you, too, right?
-Yeah -- No.
Does he get close to you?
He got close to you?
-Yeah, yeah.
I got close, too, and...
-Yeah, but I didn't --
-We were both moving closer.
-Questlove said that --
Questlove has a theory.
He said, "I'm calling it now.
"Cousin Greg is opps.
It's a sting all along."
He thinks that you're an agent.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-Like a narc?
-Oh, yeah.
-Like an inside man?
-Absolutely.
-For the government?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
-Could be right.
Could be right. Could be right.
-That could be right?
-That could be.
It could be.
-I know I'm right.
I'm calling it. Season six.
-I'm not nodding yes or no.
-We're going to play this
interview back after season six,
and we'll see how -- Yeah.
-I can't tell
what I revealed just now.
Did I reveal -- Yeah.
-But this is what
a great actor he is.
He knows exactly who he is
and he's acting like
he doesn't even know who he is.
Nicholas Braun!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nicholas Braun
in "Succession."
He's great. Watch this.
-It's not my preferred choice.
-Or mine.
I -- I thought, you know,
you said you'd never burn me.
-I said I'd try not to burn you.
-Well, no.
You said -- On the plane,
you said --
-Hey, hey. Hey, hey.
Let's not "he said, she said."
There's a lot of [bleep] said.
Look. I'm still not saying
I will burn you.
All I'm saying
is I might burn you.
It's a margin call.
-And just how bad
will the burning be?
I mean, even as I ask that,
I can tell it's not gonna be...
-Ha! Nicholas Braun, everybody!
"Succession" airs
Sundays at 9:00 p.m. on HBO.